Finding the beauty and two opposing views.
Well, I like to call that
the pretty little middle AKA balance.
Balance is where two halves make a hole
and one area this is particularly important; parenting.
Helping us today is my good friend,
friend of the show and parenting educator,
Dr. Aliza Pressman.
She's the co founding director
of the Mount Sinai Parenting Center.
And she has a podcast called Raising Good Humans.
She's one prestigious lady, Dr. Aliza,
thank you for being here.
(audience clapping)
Hello.
Let me just come out of the gate and ask you
what are some of the main issues
that parents can't seem to agree on?
Anything that pulls up your childhood memory
of being parented, which is basically discipline
your parenting styles are reflected in discipline.
Things related to boundaries setting.
I know a couple going through it,
Rachel and Brad are happily married parents of three
but here's a look at what's happening in their house.
Drew. This is a perfect example.
(gentle music)
I literally just made the kids as a real fruit smoothie
and then Brad gets home from work
and he's giving them packaged fruit snacks.
A fruit snack for you.
(indistinct)
And here's one fruit snack for you.
(baby babbling)
That kind of stuff drives me crazy.
I want to make sure that the twins don't get hungry
because if they do then it's meltdown city.
Sometimes it takes a while to cut up fresh fruit
but you're just not sure that they're gonna eat them.
Nine 9 times out of 10, when I get home from work
and Brad's already with the kids, they're on their tablets.
So let's just see!
(hinges squeaking)
Hi, guys.
Welcome home.
Hey, what are you doing June Brad.
I'm watching my tablet.
It's educational.
Sometimes I need to get things done.
I'm not bad at using screen time to occupy the children.
(gentle music)
It is very frustrating for me when
I'm the only one that's trying to make an effort
to make dinner time, a nice family conversation.
(child yelling)
(child groans)
When it's time to sit down for dinner, I'm just tired.
(child yelling)
All day, I'm telling them what they can, what they can't do.
I just want to sit down, have a nice meal with my wife
and not have to yell at the kids. (chuckles)
And when I say yell,
not have to tell the kids what they can and they can't do.
(child yelling)
Every night.
(kid groans)
(audience clapping)
Brad and Rachel, thank you for joining us
from Lake Ozark, Missouri and being here with us.
Thanks for coming on this show.
Thank you for having us.
Yeah, we need some help.
Rachel, do you feel really
like the kids see you as the bad cop?
Oh, for sure.
And I try, I feel like I'm with the kids
by myself more often than he is.
When he's home, we're both around,
so I feel like what I do
there's just more pressure on what I do.
And I feel like since I've been the disciplinary all day
I'll wait for him to sort of step in when he gets home
and do some disciplining.
And it just seems like it doesn't necessarily happen.
So to the kids, it's just like I'm the disciplinarian
and he's the fun one.
Well, and then from my perspective, you know,
I have a full-time job.
I'm also in the Navy reserves.
So I'm gone one weekend, a month, two weeks a year.
So I'm just not home a lot.
And so, you know, I don't want to come home
and then just be the disciplinary for the children,
you know, I want them to like me, of course,
'cause I'm not around as much.
Aliza, let me ask you a question.
Do you think kids see them that black and white
as good cop, bad cop?
I love that question because what Brad just said
when he said, "I want them to like me",
there's an assumption that they're not going to like you
because you give them boundaries
or have some expectation of their behavior,
but we don't actually know
what another human being is thinking
and so it's a really good opportunity to say,
maybe they feel really safe because there are boundaries
and there's some sense of what is expected of them
but with sensitivity and kindness and a sense of humor.
So there's a way to do both of those things
and be liked by your kids.
You're still their guide, not their buddy.
And so you can have both of those
but it makes so much sense
if you feel like, well, I'm not there very much.
I want them to like me.
So I just want to also straighten that out,
your kids will have respect for you and feel safe
when you create certain predictable boundaries
but also have time for fun.
And you don't need to be so attached
to every one of those rules.
So on the other side of it, letting go and saying
the world is not going to end
if we have a little bit of a crazy night.
It might be that you still go to bed on time
or you do whatever it is that's like the bigger picture
of the boundaries
but the little details don't matter so much.
Already your tone with each other, isn't negative.
You can really provoke an emotion
with a certain tone of the way you're saying things.
And you guys seem like a really strong, happy couple.
And I think what you're going through
is just really typical and we get it.
Yeah, we really try to actively put our marriage first
and be parents second, even though it's not really
I don't know, it just-
It's not easy to do at this stage.
You know, 'cause our twins are two and a half
and we have a 10 month old daughter.
So it's not easy to put each other first
and then take care of the children.
Well, Aliza, you used a certain word and it was shaming.
When you make people feel ashamed for the approach
of sort of trying to figure out your differences.
Please talk to that.
Yeah, when you jump into criticizing each other
and shamming each other about your parenting style,
all that really does is take us
into a fight-flight-or-freeze mode.
That's just a stress response that anybody gets.
So what's great is
if you are putting your marriage first,
you're removing or at least can try to remove
the judgment, the shame.
So it's not about I'm doing this right
you're doing this wrong.
It's about, let's figure out
how to do this in a way that is comfortable for both of us
since we come from totally different approaches.
Also, you guys said that every time you come home,
I heard sort of like there's a setup,
there's a dynamic where you're expecting it
to go a certain way and inevitably does
and that might be a let down.
And I think what I'd love to figure out
is how we change that.
(upbeat music)